give me a step pre-anarchy like let's
just say
we're not going to go full anarchy
hypothetically because now i get the
fact that you're an anarchist you
believe in that
the chances of that happen in america
anytime soon is slim to none of having
that
i think it's 100 that it's gonna happen
yes okay
so before we go to the argument 100
percent let me just make sure let me
clarify what i mean
by a hundred percent i don't mean that
the federal government is going to be
abolished
but i do think there is a 100 chance
within the next let's suppose 100 years
that there will be space for people to
live free without the threat of the
state
over their heads it doesn't have to be
all of america but that's not 100
anarchy though you're talking
well no it would be not worldwide but
i'm saying i get this so
so you're talking about are you talking
about like a john
galt iran type of a setting is that kind
of what you're thinking about where
they're going to create their own uh a
place where everybody kind of leaves
each other alone and
we don't have law and order we just
trust the fact that you're going to
improve i'm going to improve and we're
going to attract only people
like us you have to get it out of your
head
that anarchism is no law and order
anarchism is the mother of order when
people engage voluntarily
based on individuals it's not based on a
crime right when
people were so it's i would probably
ward it more
values and principles less law and order
right because this is a good example you
have a show
you invited me on we negotiated times we
negotiate how long it's going to take
the possibility of this getting violent
was literally zero uh we wish each other
well
and we came to mutual agreement so
there's many examples of day-to-day
basis
where people come to agreement and set
up and the rules is it's your show
and you run it like you want and if you
tell me to shut up i either shut up or
you cut me off or you hang up you know
whatever it is
you're the one who's in a position to
impose your rules but there's no real
law here whatsoever
it's something that we have
spontaneously and we do this on a
day-to-day basis with everyone we
encounter
have a mutually agreed upon negotiation
based on certain parameters that we also
mutually agree upon
yeah there's a big difference but this
is understanding mutual understanding
almost like a code that we live by
exactly
but but law and order is on paper i got
to follow that law
order in an anarchy there's not going to
be a law order it's going to be
mutual understandings that we have and
if i don't like the way you handle
yourself you and i are probably never
going to do business together and i'm
going to go my way you're going to go
your own way
so and we'll and we wish each other well
so what comes before anarchy what's
before anarchy in your eyes a
libertarian
what what is anarchy i i don't think
it's a gradual process i think it's
going to be somewhat of a binary process
but i think what needs to happen first
is a
increase in the skepticism and contempt
for the state and its actors so i think
when you're seeing
what's very healthy in this country as a
phenomenon especially on internet
circles
is enormous amount of skepticism if not
contempt toward corporate media
uh a recognition that just because
someone was elected to office the
the claim that they should have some
kind of say over your life or your
person is
bizarre if not nonsensical those are two
kind of and
also ending a very uh this is the one
i'm most excited about
and strongly increased skepticism
towards war
as a mechanism as resolving human
disputes i think we've seen that happen
in the last 20 years shift very very
hard and i'm very very excited to see
that happen so if you like this sort of
shortcut from an interview i did click
over here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
[Music]
you